[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in and as you
guys are fully aware we're stuck in a
little bit of a holding pattern when it
comes to production on hot ones but not
to worry I missed you guys and I need to
check in so I'm gonna hit you guys with
a little story a story about the time
the SWAT team raided my apartment in
college so we're throwing it back to my
junior year the end of the semester the
end of finals even I remember waking up
in the morning and feeling great cuz I
had a totally free day before I moved
home for the summer I make myself a cup
of coffee grab the mug walk out to the
balcony and there I just see a swarm of
police saying have no idea what's going
on I reach out to some of my friends
that live in the building they have no
idea what's going on and as the minutes
and hours pass the situation just gets
more intense and more intense
you can hear helicopters hovering over
the building and it's not until I turn
on the TV that I discover the real
reason why we're all locked in our
apartments I turn on the TV and I see a
breaking news report there's a reporter
standing right out in front of my
building so real experience while I'm
inside and they're talking about how
apparently there was an armed robbery on
campus or near campus and the guy took
off on foot so there's a foot race and
the guy went into the apartment building
where they lost him
so now here I am sitting on the couch
going great there's a there's a gunman
in the building lock the doors totally
unlock down and then time starts to move
really slow this is something that began
in the morning and as the hours tick on
the Sun begins to set
it's nightfall there's a mass of people
outside news trucks SWAT team police and
still no sign of the gunman on the loose
it's now nighttime and I hear Oh
on the neighbors door police open up and
I'm like oh my god it was the guy next
door the whole time I put my ear up to
the wall and I can hear hands in the air
hands in the air
are there any weapons or drugs inside
the apartment hands up and it's so
aggressive what's going on it sounds
like they're clearing rooms and I'm
thinking oh my god he was right next
door it could have been me and this guy
locked up in the apartment all day was
right next door the whole time oh my god
and then it goes quiet it goes silent
again
the minutes go by five minutes goes by
and I'm like what the hell is going on
so I go to my door and I look out the
peephole and what do I see I'm staring
down the barrel of four guns they're in
like a diamond formation
one guy's down on in me other three guys
over them and I'm just looking at four
rifles so I just immediately I'm like
boom up against the wall because I know
in that moment I'm just a fart or a
sneeze away from catching a bullet some
up against the wall and has him up
against the wall boom boom boom boom
police open up the door and what I'm
nervous about is our door was like
broken so like if you opened the door
and slam shut so I'm like great this is
gonna be like another thing I can't
explain that to them through the door in
this moment it doesn't feel like so I
just grab the door open it starts to
slam on them boom they come in full
speed guns are there any drugs or are
there any weapons inside the apartment
and you know in my head I'm like there's
probably some weed in the desk that's it
you know but I don't want to explain
that
am i incriminating myself what are they
even after day after a gunman why I
guess that must be like a thing that
they have to say like that's that's
protocol are there any guns are there
any drugs no sir
so they clear out every room they set up
a shield and they have a guy walk me out
of the apartment building holding up a
shield I get outside we had these these
poor these poor girl neighbors they were
just crying you can tell they've never
been through anything like that in their
lives neither and Vaught neither died to
be fair so now with me safe I'm sure
you're wondering well how does this
story end well it turns out the guy had
just run into the build
went to the parking garage and then he
was like hiding out in a closet like a
cleaning closet in the parking garage
they found out after they cleared out
this whole massive building
took them off to jail and that's how the
saga ended now listen I don't want
everybody going into like the regional
papers and champaign-urbana at the time
and pulling up the news story and poking
holes in it or whatever listen this is
Shawn tells a story and if that's how I
remembered it that's how it happened and
that's the story of the time the SWAT
team raided my apartment in college all
right another order of business during
quarantine my new obsession foreign
films so at the end of each one of these
story times I'm going to recommend a
foreign film and last night I watched a
great one it's called I saw the devil
Wow was it good you know if you like the
man on fire John wick movies these
revenge stories it's for you
very violent difficult to watch at times
but I enjoyed it a lot more than those
other movies and I loved those other
movies basically you just have a story
of a psychopath it kills the guy's wife
and now he's on the hunt and you don't
want to be in this guy's crosshairs so I
saw the devil is my official
recommendation and to those of you out
there you know I'm just I'm a noob in
this foreign film world so if you have
recommendations please tweet them at me
you know what I like I like an edible
settle into the love sack watch a movie
no slow burns no slow burns I have a a
DD problem I need action I need action I
need action I saw the devil 10 out of 10
we'll see you next time on Sean tells a
story
[Music]
what is up spice Lords camera guy bell
here just eaten some wings be really
cool view a viewer if that like and
subscribe button let's do this thing
[Music]
like and subscribe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
remember that time Clara bats maybe it
away now I'm out here heating as many
wins as I want
it's a big one like and subscribe
[Music]